um fran to see
if a man raises a child that he believes
is hid and the mother knows that she
lied should she be punishable by law and
what would the punishment be she should
be punished
yeah and i would i would even argue
however many years the guy spent like
raising that kid give her a gift
that's that's it's terrible that's a
terrible thing to do you deserve to be
punished you wasted that man you know
how much do you know how much like
emotion yeah he's putting into that kid
stop you from even having your own yeah
i mean
yeah
to be honest i think it's just the same
as like females lying about uh rape it's
the exact same for me to be honest it's
just say great say great youtube
great great great great saying so great
i like such a sensitive subject though
like yes yeah it's exactly the same it's
all the same right category because it
actually happens and then that people
lie so it's like when it comes up
people don't don't know whether to like
how to attach it yeah it's always
detrimental to someone's image it's true
imagine i said on your name like
your life changes literally like bro it
happened i don't know
you don't have to say a name i'm not
going to say names but obviously okay it
happened last year in it but the one
thing about me is i'm not i'm not i'm
not a bias guy like i always want to
hear two sides of the story
long story short
i did it side no one but i was still
there for the guys so if i found out it
was true i'd be like oh cool i'm gonna
have to back up but everyone else is
like oh rah rah long story short that
the guy didn't do it so this girl got
everyone against him now everyone was
just there like he boss case he's
chilling but it's like yeah the fact
that that whole time period bro yeah bro
the guy was in his room like
upset sad like he had no one bro i'm
burning around he was the one that
introduced me to everyone so everyone
just left him i was just thinking ah bro
it's one of the dumb ones like if you if
you play sports
how could you even leave your room to
even come yeah if that on your name like
everyone's gonna be looking at you
differently if you have a game there's
gonna be like oh yeah that's the guy
how's he even allowed to play
that like this is what's up right now
it's not true and they even might look
at you differently as well it's just
changed your whole character telling
literally
and that's the thing like girls even if
they don't go to the police they can
still spread that rumor around campus
yes and girls don't really question each
other on it
yeah like like if if your friend came to
you like i'm not going to be like oh was
it true like how'd that happen
so it's kind of like
i just believe it straight away yeah
literally
no i i don't always believe it but but
i'm not gonna say it like but i'm not
gonna say anything because like what if
it did happen that's that's the problem
i think it's it's a thin line between
like supporting your friend but you
still have to operate
that facts do you i mean you need to ask
questions to know yeah you know it
you're not going to question her
emotions so if if like a female went to
another female and she was very
emotional about that that topic
you're not even going to think twice
about questioning it and obviously going
to play in the back of your mind like
did it actually happen but
your first reaction would be like oh
yeah like i'm gonna just cater to you
like
you can be with me like whatever you
need i've got you
do you think that dna test should be
mandatory i think yes yes yes yes save a
lot of time
yes because boy
hundred percent
i feel like it gets to the point as well
i feel like if it was a lot of a lot of
time wasting that goes on would be quite
short like literally
yeah
for real because then you get to know
sure yeah
it doesn't even have to be mandatory but
i think because a lot of people like
they're so confident or maybe they just
they just don't want to know do you i
mean but like
even if you're just
it's an option at the end of but if
would you do when you if one of them say
yes you have to do it do you i mean it's
not like oh because i said no like we
don't have to do it like what are you
talking about but how does that work
with celebrities though so for example
like no but for example
drake mentioned in one of his songs that
one of some random girl just said oh let
me get a pregnancy test and you're just
wasting the guy's time because multiple
goals would you do the same thing over
and over again trying to
take time and crowd from him so he has
to be certain goals that
that that basically has to be a limit on
the way you do that
to protect certain individuals from
wasting weight
that's true
over and over and over again just ask
yourself
sorry but i don't i don't know you know
why am i pregnant for me for me i think
it's a thing where if you're a celebrity
and you know the status you hold and
even that comes with it first of all you
should be careful anyway
like whether you chose to become a
celebrity or not like i mean and to
it to me it doesn't whether you're a
celebrity or not you're just like
everyone else so if it's mandatory it's
mandatory bro yeah you're still here
because you're celebrating because
you're gonna get on this flight at this
time and do this isn't that you should
have thought about that before messing
about do you
that's what your life holds bro it's
like for us bro we're athletes we play
basketball you're not going to do
anything
out of that line because you know what
you need to do yeah i'm saying so now if
you're messing about and stuff and now
people are telling you to do this test
and do that yeah you got to do it bro
whether you whether you're athlete not
actually a celebrity or not bro you have
to do it
yeah i guess so because it it may waste
time but at least you're certain and you
know yeah
knowing that this is 100
then oh just skip it and now i don't
know what sport but what if you've never
met a girl before and she just made it
up then then obviously like people you
look into stuff like that and it's like
bro like i don't even know who you are
yeah i'm saying that that's
yeah dna tests have to be done still no
it's kind of hard to know like if you
have a kid or responsibility out there
and if you're able to actually cater to
that if you can't and you don't know
then that just makes your life ten times
harder because you're thinking about
that every day we're talking about the
story bro
if it's mandatory tuna girl's gonna
waste her time literally they're just
wasting her their own time because if
she knows that right at the end of this
i'm or at some point we need to do the
test and this is not true yeah they're
not gonna pick on drake all of a sudden
out of the blue just to say
and we've never even seen each other in
person in our lives because now
when it gets to it
she just found out how deep is it what's
the point of that it was the sun goes on
the cloud though like people will talk
about for example that some girls ask
you for a pregnancy test
and like they'll get like a little
publicity and some gorgeous like demons
like that
but that's the thing though um obviously
there was a time where like there was a
time where i think i don't i think it
was little dirk apparently oh she was
messing around with someone else and
then there was a kid that looked exactly
like little dirk it's a thing where we
don't know what's going on what they do
so because things that i get publicized
here like like gets baited out it's just
straight that's just cloud like stuff
like that just clap because maybe yeah
he did have a kid back then
and the baby mum and dad already know
because you don't know nothing can
people want clout now all of a sudden
he's jumping on 2022 you're saying that
oh yeah little dirk has a new kid and
she's he's cheating on india
come on bro like that's just
time-wasting you get
like but people want to just
see people fail and stuff like that
that's what i'm saying like you have a
name for yourself and everyone's like oh
really
you know what i mean oh 10 years ago you
did this to me
this just long like why why would you
want to do that to someone yeah people
don't want to see like you don't want to
honestly and it's sad though don't you
think yeah it's just the way our society
our generation is coming because
everybody just wants
certain things and some people want what
they can't have so they'll do anything
in their power to tear that down and it
makes no sense because there's no like
there's no glory at the end of the day
for you
well the crazy thing is like
you could give people an instruction
guide on how to like
no you could give them an instruction
guide on how to like accomplish what
you've accomplished they won't do it
ninety percent of the time it's true
like
in fact they'll probably be even more
pissed off that you gave it to them and
just be like well i don't need that i
don't need your help
people just
have